[Music]
I often get questions about what it's
like being a woman in science which has
traditionally been a field dominated by
men and the interesting thing is the
complexity of that to me because I grew
up in the 1980s I went to college in the
1990s and that certainly was after the
era at least for the most part where
women were just told point blank you
shouldn't be here you can't be a
scientist you don't belong here
that never happened to me I never had
anybody say to my face in terms of a
teacher you know you're not welcome here
you don't belong here
and in fact when I was in college some
of the the highest performing students
in my physics classes were women they
were certainly in the minority in terms
of numbers you know there were there
were fewer of them in class compared to
men but they were doing very well but
one of the things that's most surprising
to me and I've talked to a lot of my
women colleagues about this is that I
really didn't expect some of the biggest
barriers to come from inside myself from
the very start of my scientific career
and I'm talking about undergraduate
being a physics major I grappled with
almost crippling self-doubt it was
really hard to get myself into the class
I mean sometimes I actually had to work
myself up into a character I'd sort of
stand outside a classroom and think
about how a physics student should feel
or how they should behave
I felt very deeply that I didn't belong
there but that was coming from me that
didn't seem to be coming from anything
external through most of my career in
science and I'm talking about my
education I was too scared to ask a
single question I spent my entire
undergraduate and most of my graduate
classes in the back of the class
terrified I was copying the notes the
teacher was was deriving something on
the blackboard I was copying it down but
I mean it could have been in a foreign
language I didn't understand it and I
was so embarrassed to admit that I was
that lost in that far behind I spent my
entire scientific education being scared
and I look back and I think why you know
it turns out I now have a doctorate in
physics I I can learn that I can do
physics I can be successful at that I'm
not an idiot so why was I so crippled
and held back by my own fear and by my
own shame
at how I wasn't understanding this very
quickly I've heard people use the term
impostor syndrome that for some reason
you're absolutely sure you don't belong
here and in fact you must have fooled
people into letting you be here I've had
it pointed out that if you can pass
comprehensive exams and physics which I
have it probably means you belong here
probably means you learn the material
but it never felt that way it always
felt like maybe I had sort of pulled the
wool over people's eyes alright I you
know I shouldn't be here and I've fooled
people into thinking I belong here and
there's this sense of shame and I'm
gonna admit this to you I still feel
that today I feel that every single day
I go to NASA and I'm with these
brilliant people all around me every
single day I still feel like I don't
belong and it's been some kind of a
mistake that they let me in imagine your
whole career being like that never
feeling like you belong and I'm not
saying this is something that only
happens to women I'm sure this happens
to men too but I've had to ask myself
why it's true that society as a whole
gives you lots of very subtle messages
that you don't belong as a woman you
know it's remarkable that you're a
scientist you know I mean even we know
why is it difficult being a woman
science even those questions begin to
put you apart as something different and
the desert there's all of these tiny
little messages that you're not right my
wonderful gifted and talented counselor
in high school I loved said but you
don't have a scientist personality you
can't be a scientist you're not that
cold logical person everything about me
has been wrong and been defined as being
wrong since I was a child and I
internalized that and I have not found a
way to get beyond it
the thing that has sustained me of
course is that I have some wonderful
colleagues some of them are women many
of them are men the first person that
really encouraged me was my research
advisor in college shout out to David
Latham who saw this very scared nervous
girl who loved astronomy and he took me
under his wing he said you know you can
be in astronomers there's nothing
magical about it you don't have to be
brilliant there's not a specific
personality you have to have if you love
astronomy you can do this and he
absolutely right I do need encouragement
I do need people to say we're happy to
have you in our group we're glad you're
here I wish I didn't need that
encouragement but I do that really
really helps me
you may not realize the people around
you are struggling with that self-doubt
almost that self sabotage that they just
sort of want to run away at any time but
if I'm experiencing it I think there's a
good chance the people around you are as
well take some time to appreciate each
other take some time to take care of
each other and think about what it's
like to be a woman in general I mean I
often sort of give people this example
you know picture yourself in a world
where the roles were reversed
where every person who walked on the
moon was a woman where every president
of the United States was a woman where
every major religious figure and
philosopher and artist and musician and
all the top chefs and you know all the
authors they were all women and yeah
okay there's an occasional man here and
there and we call them out and encourage
them and make examples of them but
you're in this whole world where the
right way to be is to be a woman and a
lot of people I think need to put
themselves in that and really think
about it what does it like being told
subtly that everything about you is
wrong and somehow less from the moment
you're born the universe has inspired me
since I was a child this was nothing
faked I wanted to look at the Stars when
I was a little kid as soon as I could
walk my mom would find me out there
trying to look at the Stars the universe
picks people to be fascinated by it it
can be any gender or ethnic group or
socio-economic group I've met people
from so many different walks of life who
love the Stars and they can't even tell
you why that's my tribe I belong to a
group of people that for some reason
love astronomy inspired by space and by
the universe and nothing can change that
nothing can ever take that away even my
self-doubt so I've lived a life kind of
steeped in fear but I've also found such
beauty in such inspiration it's
complicated I'm still kind of a mess but
I'm moving forward and I'm I have that
inspiration that connection to the
universe that will never go away
[Music]